fear is serious business so it makes
sense that anyone with serious screaming
skills might turn out to be pretty good
at showcasing enough of a range of
emotions to become somebody in Hollywood
here are a few scream queens who became
a listers Charlize Theron for her role
of serial killer Aileen Wuornos in 2003
s monster actress Charlize Theron won an
Oscar her loyalty to hair-raising
Hollywood Pictures is perhaps due in
part to the fact that she got her start
in the horror genre with a small role in
1995's children of the corn three urban
harvest Jennifer Aniston long before
Jennifer Aniston became America's
Sweetheart is Rachel Green and Friends
she made her feature film debut in the
1993 comedy slasher flick leprechaun she
plays a teen who has to survive a
maniacal leprechaun hell-bent on
recovering his stolen treasure once
Aniston established herself as a rom-com
regular though she mostly steered clear
but he boned chillerz Sarah Michelle
Gellar
she's probably best known for her
starring role in the Buffy the Vampire
Slayer TV series but Sarah Michelle
Gellar easily parlayed her role as a
monster fighting TV heroine onto the big
screen as a career started taking off in
1997 Gellar starred in a pair of
slashers playing Doom the beauty pageant
winner Helen shivers and I know what you
did last summer answer rd Sister CC and
scream to Sharon Stone throughout her
career Sharon Stone has proven she has a
basic instinct for selecting solid
starring roles but before she was a star
she was just another struggling actress
take for example her theatrical debut in
1981 s deadly blessing a West Craven
production that might have seemed like a
sure thing given the director had
already established himself with some
solid horror movie credits the pic was
both panned and ignored by audiences but
it did nothing to stop the eventual
Oscar nominee from ascending to a higher
profile a few years later Mila Kunis her
most celebrated role to date came as the
unsettling ballerina Lily in the eerie
2010 thriller Black Swan but Mila
Kunis's first true terror role came
courtesy of the 1995 remake of Parana it
wasn't the last time she'd try her hand
to thrillers and it may not have been
the worst she also appeared in the
critically eviscerated American Psycho
to Allah
American girl and a 2007 straight-to-dvd
dud bootcamp Renee Zellweger
she might have had everyone at hello and
a breakthrough role in the 1996 hit
Jerry Maguire
but before Renee Zellweger started
tugging on heartstrings and rom-coms
like Bridget Jones diary she did a stint
in the horror house her role in Texas
Chainsaw Massacre the next generation
was filmed long before she shot the
recognition but released shortly after
her career started to flourish
[Music]
yikes drew barrymore after her memorable
role in Steven Spielberg's et the
extra-terrestrial tiny scene-stealer
drew Barrymore followed her breakout
success with back-to-back Stephen King
adaptations 1984 firestarter in 1985 s
cat's-eye Barrymore's career cooled
later in the 80s but she returned the
thriller and horror genres while
building a comeback starring in the
early 90s efforts poison ivy no place to
hide and doppelganger her opening cameo
and Wes Craven scream offered an obvious
nod to her significant scream queen
credentials Jamie Lee Curtis like her
mother
psycho star Janet Leigh Jamie Lee Curtis
is probably best known for her
considerable horror movie roots in fact
Curtis is first silver screen appearance
is pretty much what launched her career
in 1978 she starred as Michael Myers
tortured sister John Carpenter's
Halloween the first of four times she'd
appear in the role over the course of
the franchise until 2002 most recently
she appeared on Fox's cheeky small
screen slasher satire scream queens as a
bit of an homage to her own status as a
lady legend in the field outside of the
genre Curtis has also garnered plenty of
recognition
she's a Golden Globe and BAFTA winning
actress but in spite of her many
subsequent accomplishments she'll always
probably be known for the closet scene
in Halloween really how do you ever top
that Demi Moore
just before Demi Moore became a member
of the 80s hit-making squad known as a
brat pack she appeared in a little-known
critically despised 1982 sci-fi horror
flick called parasites it must kill to
survive
ultimate predator it wasn't her only
stent with the otherworldly she also
started the 1988 apocalyptic thriller
the seventh sign and the 1990
supernatural romantic drama ghost and
she went on to accrue her fair share of
acclaim in non genrih efforts obviously
despite initially unfavorable reviews
her turn and parasite didn't gnaw way at
her career prospects thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know who your favorite scream queen is